searching for work during the holiday so
maybe less difficult than you think
because of the strong economy tomorrow
the Labor Department releases the
November jobs report economists expect
employers created about 180,000 jobs
the unemployment rate was likely 3.6
percent near a 50-year low that is good
news
CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here to sort it out sort
it all out
I've always heard Jill that don't put
your house on the market don't look for
a job after Thanksgiving because ain't
nobody hiring but Anthony Mason can say
your dog profit foundation researcher
we're very happy in the family I think
people are surprised to learn that there
are December jobs that are really hot
jobs and here's why when they are still
posted in December it usually means the
company or the organization really needs
to fill it a lot of hiring managers say
to me look if we've got that job up
there it's usually because someone left
unexpectedly there's a problem and we
don't want to go back and have to get
this reproved next year go through
another budget process certain jobs that
fall into that category no like it's
totally buy that no it's totally company
specific but I will say this because of
this that you should really keep that
job search going also just imagine if
you keep it going now you do have a leg
up when it comes to January but seasonal
hiring has actually been dropping for
like the last six years hasn't it yes
and I think this is interesting seasonal
hiring on in many places has gone down
however temp and gig workers are
certainly going out there and filling
these jobs many of them at certain
companies like a Target or UPS convert
into full-time jobs I kind of think
about a temp worker in the holiday it's
like a try before you buy on both sides
so we can work really well since it's
the holiday season and people are all
trying to cross people off their gift
list if you have a family we're looking
for a job can you give them something to
help the search I think what's really
helpful is you go in for those jobs that
seek soft skills right and those are the
things that are what is good a lot of
people will say we want people who have
communication skills work well with
groups critical thinking so if you think
about that you can actually help
somebody by signing them up for a public
speaking class even better I did a fun
thing last year end of the year I went
through a bunch of executives I said
what was the best
you learned when you came into the
organization someone said an improv
class so imagine you take an improv
class sign your friend up or your kid up
for an improv class learn to think on
their feet it's so valuable so what are
some of the ways really that people can
take advantage during this time well you
know if you are still looking for a job
or starting your search it's so great
December networking central right
holiday parties reach out to people and
stay engaged and looking for a job
don't say that say hey we don't want to
wish you a happy holiday and stay
engaged and we'll reach out to you after
the first of the year don't get hammered
at your holiday party and don't tell
people you're looking for a job don't
you know just reach out just a soft
touch all right thanks